-Greetings, lords and ladies.
I'm here with the one and only
Post Malone.
And today we're gonna kick it
old-school, really old-school.
We're at Medieval Times.
It's fantastic.
You look incredible.
At this point, actually,
in Medieval times,
you're actually Pre Malone.
-Hmm. Yet To Be Malone.
-Yeah, Yet --
You have not Malone'd yet.
I am so pumped for this.
Let's do it!
♪♪
[ Horse whinnies ]
We are at Medieval Times.
-This is the best day
of my life.
♪♪
-All right, my lords.
We have your feast.
-Thank you very much.
-Oh, my God.
Thank you so much.
-Roasted chicken.
Roasted potato.
-I like --
I like mashed potatoes better.
-Mashed potatoes?
-Yeah.
Thank you so much.
♪♪
-My lords, I am most pleased
to welcome you to my castle.
-My queen.
-My lord Post, might I add,
I am a big fan of your work.
I really love your song
"Sunflower."
-Thank you. Oh, thank you.
-Are you a fan of
"The Tonight Show"?
-We don't have television
in Medieval times, my lord.
-But you have Spotify?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Ride forth, Yellow Knight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, baby.
-That's our dude.
-Come on, baby.
-There's Jonathan Van Ness
from "Queer Eye."
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Ride forth, the Red Knight!
-Boo! Sir.
-Boo, sir!
-I've seen squires
ride better than you!
-Ohh! Medieval burn!
♪♪
-Ohh!
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ You probably think that you
see yellow now, yellow now ♪
-I think we need
to get out there.
-Let's do this, man.
♪♪
-Lords and ladies,
Jimmy Fallon and Post Malone!
♪♪
-I couldn't even see
where this is.
-This helmet's heavy as [bleep].
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Knights, take up your weapons
and fulfill your oath!
-Oath!
It's hard to move.
My ass is sweating.
-Sweat.
[ Grunting ]
[ Crowd chanting ]
-Post, I challenge thee
to a joust!
-You lily-livered rapscallion!
-Challenge has been issued
and accepted!
-♪ You know you make me
want to joust ♪
♪ Take my hands up and joust ♪
♪ Come on, now ♪
-♪ Joust ♪
-♪ Don't forget to say
you will, joust ♪
♪ Come on, now ♪
-♪ Joust ♪
-♪ Don't forget to say
you will, joust ♪
-Take your places, my lords.
And may your lance
find its mark.
Now ride!
♪♪
-Oh, wow.
-Ohh.
-[ Groaning ]
-Oh. Ah. That one hurt.
-My leg!
-Oh, no. Oh, no.
Ow, ow, ow.
[ Laughter ]
[ Groaning ]
♪♪
I have one more
surprise for you.
Your Majesty.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I hereby dub thee...
Lord Post Malone
of Medieval Times.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Well done, my lord.
-I just hugged the queen!
-I know you did!
-Yeah! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Medieval Times!